My name is Diakalola Amujum. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the Clean Sight application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified
我叫Diakalola Amujum。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业。我也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的人。Marion博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中给予了我极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这对我非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些已经获得资格的心理学家和正在接受培训的心理学家的经历。
and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. How many times have you been told no and it's changed the direction of your life. A relationship breakup, a disappointing email, someone not offering you a job. But what if the first answer isn't always the right answer? Today I want to explore the psychology of hearing no, why we're so quick to believe it and why sometimes asking just one more question can change everything. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Welcome to Inner Work.
以及正在接受培训的临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学的旅程提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。你被拒绝过多少次，而这又改变了你的人生方向？一段关系的破裂、一封令人失望的邮件、某人没有给你提供工作机会。但如果第一个答案并不总是正确的答案呢？今天我想探讨一下听到“不”的心理学，为什么我们如此轻易地相信它，以及为什么有时再多问一个问题就能改变一切。我是Marianne Trent博士。欢迎来到《内在工作》。
I think that one of the reasons that it hurts so bad to be told, is if we really go back to our very early brain roots, being kind of a mammal community, being accepted by others is very much key to our survival. So when we are shunned, when we're told no, when there's boundaries are put in place, it can make us feel really vulnerable and very much a threat. So I think it activates that kind of sense of danger. I'm a youngest child, and I do think there's something a little bit linked to bird. order here as well because my youngest child who's just turned 10 he will hear no he doesn't
我认为被拒绝之所以让人如此痛苦，原因之一是如果我们回到我们非常原始的大脑根源，作为哺乳动物群体的一员，被他人接纳对我们的生存至关重要。因此，当我们被排斥、被拒绝、被设定界限时，这会让我们感到非常脆弱，并感到极大的威胁。所以我认为这激活了那种危险感。我是家里最小的孩子，我确实认为这与出生顺序也有点关系，因为我刚满10岁的小儿子，他听到“不”时，他不会
really take that as a final offer if he's not happy with that he will go on and on and on and on wearing me down until eventually I'll be right okay we'll do that thing it isn't constant and I am aware that it's that intermittent reinforcement that is the hardest thing to break, so I probably have made that rod for my own back. And what we're not talking about here is we're not talking about breaking people down, kind of if they said no to wanting to be intimately involved with you or kind of pursuing anything sexually. So please, obviously, no, often does mean no. That's not what we're talking about here. Whilst I do try and teach people that no is a complete sentence, it rarely is just said so succinctly. And even when it is, our brain will often
真的把它当作最终决定。如果他不满意，他会没完没了地纠缠，直到最后我妥协说“好吧，我们就那样做吧”。这并不总是发生，我也意识到这种间歇性强化是最难打破的，所以我可能给自己挖了个坑。我们在这里讨论的不是那种打破人们底线的情况，比如如果他们拒绝了与你亲密接触或追求任何性关系。所以请注意，显然，“不”通常确实意味着“不”。我们讨论的不是这个。虽然我确实试图教导人们“不”是一个完整的句子，但它很少被说得那么简洁。即使是这样，我们的大脑也经常
provide other reasons that may or may not be true. You know, you're not good enough, you're too old, you're too young, you know, you're too tall, you're too short, you're too something else, you know, you're never going to get there. This was your only chance that can make this one know that you're given really snowball and you can kind of very easily become your own worst inner critic. So, I know it's difficult when I get emails or news that is different than what I want, because actually when we want something, you know, we've done our best to ask for it, to have our needs met, and then someone goes,
提供其他可能正确也可能不正确的理由。你知道，你不够好，你太老了，你太年轻了，你太高了，你太矮了，你太……其他什么了，你知道，你永远不会成功。这是你唯一的机会，这会让你得到的这个“不”像滚雪球一样，你很容易就会成为自己最严厉的内心批评者。所以，我知道当我收到与我预期不同的邮件或消息时，这很困难，因为实际上当我们想要某样东西时，我们已经尽力去争取了，去满足我们的需求了，然后有人说，
no, no, this is not for you, this is not your path for destiny. You're like, I wanted that, I really wanted that. And, you know, but also it can just make us feel like, yeah, critical and hurt. And I find that rather than reacting straight away, giving myself some time to let that percolate, through, I am, I think, on balance, quite creative and sometimes just giving me a couple of days to have a think around something and to maybe come up with a different way, a different proposal, a different way of doing something that still meets my needs, but maybe helps others kind of
“不，不，这不适合你，这不是你的命运之路。”你会想，我想要那个，我真的很想要那个。而且，这也会让我们感到受伤和自我怀疑。我发现与其立即做出反应，不如给自己一些时间让它沉淀。总的来说，我认为我还是很有创造力的，有时只需给自己几天时间思考一下，也许能想出一种不同的方式、不同的提议，或者一种既能满足我的需求，又能帮助他人理解为什么这真的是个好主意的不同做法。
see why this would be a really good idea. That can be really helpful in work situations. Now, obviously, you don't want to be the one that, like my 10-year-old son, is going on and on and on. So it's about picking the balance, picking the battles that are right for you to fight for. And I think this episode really came up for me because of the conversation I had with Esther Tio about the BPS equivalence route where she was initially told, no, you haven't met the criteria. But actually when she dug a little deeper, she realized that the wrong email had been responded to. They just hadn't really grasped what it was that she was asking. And it had been a case of basically computer says no because the humans have.
这在工作场合真的很有帮助。当然，你不想成为像我10岁儿子那样没完没了纠缠的人。所以关键在于把握平衡，选择那些值得你去争取的战斗。我认为这一集之所以出现，是因为我与Esther Tio关于BPS等效途径的对话，她最初被告知“不，你不符合标准”。但实际上，当她深入挖掘时，她意识到对方回复错了邮件。他们只是没有真正理解她想要什么。这基本上就是“电脑说不”，因为人类并没有。
hadn't really seen for the meaning, because I think it is still quite uncommon as a root. So I think, yeah, just be really clear that what you are being turned down for is what you actually applied for. Does it make sense? Or does some of the phraseology, you're like, hmm, I'm not sure that I think there was maybe a miscommunication here. So it's always makes sense to have a read of it. Maybe ask someone else to read an email or a text message, get some different insight because they might be able to do that in a slightly less emotionally involved way. Even if they care greatly about you, you are the main player in your life and so they might be less moved by the immediate distress of that and more able to see some
真正看到其中的含义，因为我认为这作为一种途径仍然相当罕见。所以我想，是的，一定要非常清楚你被拒绝的是你实际申请的东西。这有意义吗？或者某些措辞让你觉得“嗯，我不确定这里是否存在误解”。所以阅读一下总是很有意义的。也许请别人读一读邮件或短信，获得一些不同的见解，因为他们可能能够以一种情感投入较少的方式来处理。即使他们非常关心你，你也是你自己生活的主角，所以他们可能不太会被那种即时的痛苦所触动，而更能看到一些
of the nuance. I know a number of people who were in relationships and then their partner decided that I'm not really sure this is going to work for us and it was of course, devastating for the other person. But you know over time they asked for you know the position to be reviewed and they've been together you know very happily for many years so relationship breakups aren't always you know terminal isn't always the end of the line and so yeah I think sometimes we are we're so inbuilt to respect the work know, to be respectful of people in positions of power as well. Let's just give ourselves a little bit
细微差别。我认识一些人，他们处于恋爱关系中，然后他们的伴侣决定“我不确定这是否适合我们”，这对另一个人来说当然是毁灭性的。但你知道，随着时间的推移，他们要求重新考虑这个决定，他们已经非常幸福地在一起很多年了。所以关系破裂并不总是终点，并不总是死胡同。所以是的，我认为有时我们天生就习惯于尊重“不”，尊重那些身居高位的人。让我们给自己一点
of permission to be curious about the no, to think about whether there's any boundary we could push or explore. I think if you do hit a hard stop, a hard no, it can be a really important time to reassess your values, your priorities, to think about your goals and where it is that you want to go and how you might get there. Some of the things I've been talking about. told no to in the past have shaped my life to lead me to the life I live now and the one that I enjoy and the one that I enjoy. If I'd been told yes earlier on in my career for different roles or even for doctorate in clinical psychology applications, I wouldn't be here. I likely wouldn't have my husband or my children. I'm recording this on a really hot day and I
许可去对这个“不”保持好奇，去思考是否有我们可以推动或探索的界限。我认为如果你确实遇到了硬性拒绝，那可能是一个重新评估你的价值观、优先事项，思考你的目标以及你想去哪里以及如何到达那里的重要时刻。我过去被拒绝的一些事情塑造了我现在的生活，让我过上了我享受的生活。如果我在职业生涯早期被告知“是”，或者在申请临床心理学博士时被告知“是”，我就不会在这里了。我可能不会有我的丈夫或我的孩子。我是在一个非常炎热的日子录制这个节目的，我
wouldn't have my in-laws lovely cool house to go and sit in to to give me a break from my own hot box of the house. So yeah, what have you learned about yourself? How has your life been shaped by nose? And have you ever been able to gently push back on those nodes? I would love to know in the comments. I hope you've enjoyed this episode of Inner Work. I've tagged another one in the end screen that I think you'll really enjoy too.
就不会有我公婆家那个凉爽的房子可以去坐坐，让我从自己那个像烤箱一样的房子里解脱出来。所以，关于你自己，你学到了什么？你的生活是如何被那些“不”所塑造的？你是否曾经能够温和地反驳那些“不”？我很想在评论区知道。希望你喜欢这一集的《内在工作》。我在结束画面中标记了另一集，我想你也会非常喜欢的。
Thanks for being part of my world. The next episode of Inner Work is available. wherever you get your podcasts and on YouTube from 8pm Wednesday, UK time. Thank you again. Take care. See you soon. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist.
感谢你成为我世界的一部分。下一集《内在工作》将于英国时间周三晚上8点在各大播客平台和YouTube上发布。再次感谢。保重。再见。你好，我叫Veronica Kassova。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，Marion向我推荐了《临床心理学家集体》，我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们看到了那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。
The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, growth and the final results will come as a byproduct. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf.
这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙述才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。我最珍视的故事中一个共同的主题是，不仅要对他人的痛苦感同身受，也要对自己宽容。此外，不要执着于成为心理学家，而是享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。Marion，感谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有志成为心理学家的人都应该在书架上放一本。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。